انتهى التمرد المسلح للباغوسيين الأفغان
في روسيا بعد ساعات فقط من واحد من
أكثر التحديات جرأة التي
شهدتها سلطة فلاديمير بوتين على الإطلاق، وبينما قد تكون هذه المواجهة قد تم
انتشارها في الوقت الحالي، فإن التهديد الذي يواجه
نظام بوتين قد يكون بعيدًا عن أن
يظهر زعيم فاغنر مدى سهولة
يمكنه الاستيلاء على منشأة عسكرية روسية كبرى
والمدينة ثم إرسال
طوابير من القوات تتجه نحو موسكو. وكان
بعض مرتزقة فاغنر في منتصف الطريق إلى
العاصمة عندما
أمرهم بروجسيان فجأة بإعادة نداء شخصي من
رئيس بيلاروسيا، ويُنسب إلى حليف بوتين المقرب
الفضل في إقناعه.
باغوسيان يلغي
زعيم الشيشان المتمرد، حليف بوتين القوي
ينتقد إيفجيني باغوسان متهماً إياه
بالغطرسة ويقتبس خلط
الطموحات التجارية مع المسائل ذات
الأهمية الوطنية، حيث نشر رمضان كالديروف
على برقية يوم السبت قائلًا إنه
كانت هناك حاجة إلى إجراءات صارمة
لوقف تمرد فاغنر الذي يمكن أن
أدت إلى إراقة الدماء،
وذكرت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية في وقت سابق يوم السبت أنه
تم نشر 3000 من مقاتليها على
استعداد لدعم الرئيس الروسي إذا
لزم الأمر.